well guys it is now that time of year it
is the time of year in which I can let
loose I can just flip out about the
absolute pieces of shit that have come
out in 2013
prepare yourself guys this is gonna be
fun
before I name my top ten worst of the
year I do have some dishonorable
mentions these are films that didn't
quite make the list but they still suck
ass grown-ups to Adam Sandler decided to
make a sequel for the first time ever
why did he choose grownups who knows
Hansel and Gretel who remembers that
anybody remember that I do 21 and over
just people getting drunk and partying
with no consequences whatsoever you know
cuz that's that's how you're supposed to
live RIPD what a piece of crap
wow what a bad movie The Lone Ranger I
feel sorry for westerns I like westerns
westerns need a comeback
it wasn't from the Lone Ranger Walking
with Dinosaurs a movie that should have
had all the dialogue removed and just
been a Discovery Channel movie and
finally after Earth M night Shyamalan I
feel sorry for you man you made some
great movies you inspired me a lot with
some of your first few films but you
have fallen my friend you have fallen
from grace I thought after earth for
sure was probably going to be in this
list but I saw ten other films that I
hated even more and here we go at number
ten we have for me what was the most
disappointing film of the entire year I
had to think about this what was my most
disappointing film of the entire year
and without a doubt it was a good day to
die hard a more apt title would have
been a good day to die just die go away
and die never make a movie again Jon
Mohr you suck as a filmmaker
you are a horrible director and I hate
your films get out of here
you ruined one of the best franchises
ever there wasn't even a fight scene and
die hard 5 John McClane did not have a
fight scene what the hell is that even
about the main villain tap dances while
eating a carrot what what
and then that's actually not the main
villain it's just some other guy who
wants a new killer something or other
who's been walking around within the
whole time such a horrible movie they
completely lost the entire essence of
John McClane as a person huh I hate that
movie I also made a review called
everything that's wrong with die hard 5
if you would like more information about
that at number nine such a stupid movie
called getaway starring Selena Gomez and
Ethan Hawke and Jon Voight as a mouth
this was a movie that is literally a
non-stop car chase filmed by the guy who
made Dungeons & Dragons I mean that's
just a recipe for greatness right no it
sucks
hmm none of the action scenes were
filmed with remotely any Flair no
professionalism to be found in this
movie at all it was just a giant
crapshoot of a whole bunch of cars
crashing everywhere shots shot with like
HD webcams jumping and flipping all over
the place jump cuts here and there and
of course Selena Gomez what more can you
want from a movie at number 8 we have
one of the most maddeningly confusing
and stupid movies that was so
self-important that thought it was so
freakin good but it was awful the
counselor what was that about literally
what was that about cuz I don't know I
mean there were actors in the movie
trying to give good performances like
Michael Fassbender and Brad Pitt but
everyone else in the film was just like
hey I'm in a really Scott movie and you
know that means it's good right no
actually Ridley Scott really did not
make a very good movie at all the script
by famous author Cormac McCarthy was his
first screenplay and it shows I hated
this movie none of it made sense it was
so confusing Cameron Diaz humped a
windshield what happened at number 7 we
have a film probably not too many people
saw it was really straight to iTunes and
the PlayStation Network it was in
theaters but most people probably saw it
at home if anyone saw it at all the
director of Ghost Rider gave us killing
season John Travolta and Robert De Niro
facing off in the woods and they torture
each other and John Travolta has the
worst Serbian accent ever and any time
any of these actors did anything that
looked remotely physically challenging
it was just like the worst
obvious stunt-double I've ever seen or
the camera would literally just film
from their neck below as someone ran so
they wouldn't show their head yeah I
mean it's really that bad and number six
what kind of year would it be if a
Stephenie Meyer adaptation wasn't on
this list does anyone remember the host
good I'm glad for you you are a lucky
person I unfortunately do because I sat
through it this movie was so horrific
Lee melodramatic and cheesy the romance
in it was the most absurd
Twilight attempt at being Twilight they
were just trying to do another big teen
franchise where there's some sort of a
love triangle where there are people
involved with it who suck at speaking
and it was just so horrible at number
five we have the second film and a
series that is continuing to make people
want to die and that is the Smurfs - I
don't like that movie I don't like it I
don't like that movie it's poop I hate
it it's poop I didn't realize I selling
the guy from anchorman Ron - poop mouth
bit poop out of your mouth I really
don't like the Smurfs I really don't
they're just stupid stupid movies aimed
at kids that are supposed to make your
kids sit down in the seat and deal with
it and not talk for like 90 minutes
except this movie is longer than it
needs to be this movies just aren't
funny at all they're filled with endless
product placement from Sony tablets it's
just disgusting at number four we have a
very early 2013 film that came out in
January as usual the first week of
January is generally filled with horror
garbage that Hollywood shits out of its
asshole coming up in January we got
Devil's Due in Paranormal Activity the
marked ones as I tell you guys it
happens every year
in 2013 we had Texas Chainsaw 3d an
actual sequel to Texas Chainsaw Massacre
indeed it was because it started out
retelling some of the events of the
first
and then it was just an endless horror
teen bloodbath of what it was it again
the woman inherits like her aunts house
or something or someone in her family
and then like at the end of the movie
she finally finds this letter that
somebody kept saying hey you should look
around and read the back of that letter
the back of letter it's like hey your
cousin is in the basement he's kind of a
giant dick yeah he likes to kill people
with a chainsaw like maybe the entire
movie wouldn't have happened if she had
jizz read that I hate that movie at
number three we have a film that yeah
yeah paranoia yeah I mean liam hemsworth
running in this movie the scenes on
youtube now if you want to look it up
this is a thriller that's not thrilling
in any way that's my best way to
describe this movie there's nothing
about this film that worked at all
there's nothing about the movie that is
redeeming it whatsoever even though
Harrison Ford Gary Oldman are in the
film they're both just trying and that's
all they could do is try because there's
nothing here the acting is terrible the
script is even worse and the direction
is even worse at number two we have a
film that some may argue was not
actually a 2013 theatrical release
because it was originally made for
television well I would argue back that
it was so popular amongst the idiot
crowd that it got a theatrical release
for one night and I saw sharknado now
look this is a movie that knows it's
dumb okay these guys knew they were
making a dumb movie but they could have
at least made it entertaining there's a
tornado filled with sharks and they're
flying around on land eating people that
sounds amazing right unfortunately it
really wasn't that funny or entertaining
at all you'd have to be completely
stone-cold wasted to enjoy this movie
and since I barely drink at all I'm
sitting there watching this movie like
everything about this movies giant crap
fest I mean but the guys knew they were
making that when they made this movie
they knew that I mean sharknado the
movie's famous because of his title
seriously that's their only reason it's
famous and they're making another one
whay and apparently it's called
sharknado 2 the second one I can't wait
to not watch that alright guys you may
have been able to guess because I
dedicated an entire video about why this
movie is wrong my number one pick for
worst film of 2013 is one of the most
disgraceful and amazingly awful films
I've ever seen in my life not just this
year movie 43 this movie is filled to
the brim with huge oscar-winning stars
who were literally guilt-tripped into
being in this movie like certain actors
have come out and been like yeah they
basically guilt tricked me into being
this movie like they moved the set to
where I live and they waited months and
months and even years to get some of
these actors just do a couple like 2
second clip or something and they'd be
like look yeah we actually got a scene
with Kate Winslet Hugh Jackman oh wow
those are there in the movie ok well
I'll do it too oh it's great oh thanks
Richard Gere oh thanks Halle Berry oh
thanks I'm a stone Oh
thanks everybody you guys suck I lost
respect for all of you i watch this
movie and I'm like what are you guys
doing what guys doing what are you doing
movie 43 the voices in their head were
clearly not working cuz one was like
it's a good idea do it the other one was
like it's gonna be shit you're gonna
ruin your career
they sure to listen to that one my best
way to describe how horrible this movie
is is to paraphrase a quote from one of
the Farley brothers one of the makers of
this film he basically said that
audience members nowadays have very
short attention spans and this is the
type of entertainment that he thinks
people enjoy watching so thanks
basically what you're saying is you
don't respect your audience that's why
your movie sucks ass because you don't
respect your audience you won't make a
good movie respect your fucking audience
man didn't make a good movie if you
don't it's gonna suck and movie 43 did I
feel so much better now guys I really do
I just wanna I just feel better I just I
really feel better I really I just want
to go you know I'm just gonna go I feel
so much better guys thanks as always
again for watching on another really fun
year I do have my best of 2013 video out
right now as well
currently on my channel if you guys want
to check that out as well guys it's been
a fun year there's been some absolute
crap like this
but I always loved talking
you guys about these movies no matter
how I feel about them thanks so much as
always for watching this year guys and
as always if you like this you can click
right here and get stuck Minh eyes